bien d'un billet vous voyez nous sommes
fidèles à tous les rendez vous que vous
donnez sur les films que vous tournez et
cette fois-ci vous enfermez le deuxième
film avec color lautner car il a déjà
fait un film avec tweet oui j'ai déjà
tourné avec l'open air le match grève
comme je sais pas si vous l'avez vu déjà
mais qui est sortie cet hiver à paris
alors cette fois ci il s'agit d'un sujet
un peu différent oui c'est un sujet très
très différent c'est un sujet somme qui
peut paraître un sujet de guerre mais
qui en réalité n'est pas ensuite guère
ce l'histoire d'un homme qui est surtout
un homme de bonne volonté qui est
victime de sa gentillesse et sa ponte il
n'en est pas victime mais enfin disons
qu'il en meurt tout de même parce que il
a tout contre lui l'adversité la sottise
humaine en temps de guerre
particulièrement pour un prix un terme à
peu usé disons que c'est un sujet humain
avant toute chose ça je ne sais pas
c'est public qui le dira et faber
habillé je dois vous poser une question
s'évadant un peu de notre propos
habituels sur ce film que pensez-vous de
la tendance actuelle du cinéma français
voilà que tourné deux films avec un
jeune metteur en scène
conséquence est un peu une indication il
semble que le tournis facilement vers un
jeune metteur en scène vous voulez
parler de ce qu'on appelle la nouvelle
vague
oui et non mais non parce que pour moi
ça n'existe pas il ya toujours et des
nouvelles vagues
personnellement j'en ai connu trois ou
quatre alors je ça n'a aucune importance
il ya des jeunes metteurs en scène moi
j'en suis personnellement ravi
maintenant de là à dire qu'ils ont un
style qui a une nouvelle vague ça c'est
pas vrai il ya des types qui ont des
chances qu'ils sont jeunes tant mieux
ils font des films et ils sont tous très
différents les uns des autres
je crois pas disjoncter nouvelle vague
pour moi c'est une invention de
journalistes ça ne veut rien dire votre
réponse me remplit de joie était
toujours notre opinion nous avons
défendu ici alors mal à briller
maintenant dans la série de rôles vous
avez dû et combien avez-vous tenu au
cinéma pro supporte vous n'êtes pas
content et non des au théâtre au théâtre
une figurine dizaine de pièces
importantes
oui ses 125 ans et d'endosser rôle
qu'elle est celui du pauvre est le
meilleur souvenir
je porte je n'y pense pas c'est sa
chance et comme les livres sayad moment
on est mieux lire un livre qu'un autre
je vois que les souvenirs de comédiens
bay en actions qu'on aime bien ça change
tout le temps pour les heures il ya
quelques années je mets beaucoup me
souvenir de tels films mais maintenant
je ne vais me souvenir de telle autre
on le puissant que les meilleurs films
sont ceux qui restent à faire ce que dès
qu'un fils du finning commune plus
beaucoup d'intérêt que c'est une salle
chauffée cultivateurs en spectateur aux
lecteurs
c'est pour nous une fois qu'il est fini
c'est fini ouais bien sûr pour le
spectateur il peut rester un classique
pour les quelques tours mais blessé mais
ya déjà eu de la chance mais bon oui il
a lui même de très bons la namibie et
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez pas répondre
mais je vais tourner un film en italie
avec camerini et ensuite je tourne un
film en france moins de 9 ans était
encore tout à fait officielle n'est pas
trop en parler